والان سنتحدث عن الموقع الذي يكتسب شهره
كبيره وهو تيك توك الصيني المشهور لا
يستخدمه الصينيون مشاهدينا لماذا الاسباب
تتعلق بالامان والمحتوى وحمايه
المستخدمين وفقا لتقرير تقني استخباراتي
امريكي اذا منصه تيك توك التي باتت احدى
اكثر التطبيقات شعبيه في العالم ليست كذلك
في الصين فبلد المليار يعتمد على نسخه
اخرى من تطبيق تيك توك تقدم منتجا اقل
ضررا ومصمما لحمايه شبابها في التفاصيل
التقرير افاد وهذا التقرير ايضا هو
لتقنيين مختصين من وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
قال ان الصين تعتمد اصدار اصدارا محليا
لتطبيق تيك توك يدعى دوين وله قوانينه
التي تحمي
المستخدمين فدويين مشاهدينا
نفس مزايا تيك توك تقريبا لكن مع اختلاف
جوهري واحد حيث يطلب من المستخدمين الذين
تقل اعمارهم عن 14 عاما استخدام وضع
المراهقين من اجل حمايتهم وللحد من تاثرهم
بشكل سلبي ماذا يفعل دوين يقيد استعمالهم
له ب 40 دقيقه يوميا بين الساعه السادسه
صباحا والعاشره مساء وذلك لضمان حصولهم
على قسط كاف من النوم كما لا يعرض عليهم
سوى محتوى ملهم مختار خصيصا
وبنايه من مواد علميه وصحيه وغيرها حسب ما
اكد ياكولا ستايلان كبير مسؤولي البرامج
في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه لصحيفه نيويورك
بوست كذلك وبعكس تيك توك الذي نحن نعرفه
ونستخدمه والذي يستخدم طبعا خارج الصين
يراقب دويين ايضا عبر مجموعه من الاجراءات
الوقائيه الوقت الذي يقضيه المستخدم
الصيني اليافع ايضا على المنصه وانواع
المحتوى المستهلكه اثناء المشاهده
[موسيقى]